LODRO RINZLER: Hello, everyone.
How are you?
It's Monday, we're at
work, and you're good?
Good.
It's funny.
I haven't walked in here
and I saw the big screen
of The Buddha Walks
into the Office up there
and I thought, if
I were you, I would
think I was going to talk
about how meditation is going
to help me be better at work.
Is that what you
guys are thinking?
OK, we're not going to do that.
And I totally understand
where you might think that.
And it does help you.
It helps you in many ways.
There are all these
studies that have
been done in terms
of people who've only
done about eight
weeks of meditation--
just little bits
of it every day--
and over that period
of those eight weeks,
they actually were testing
their brain activity,
and they saw more
activity in the ACC, which
is the segment of the
brain that really regulates
self-regulation-- so taking
away our knee jerk reactions,
slimming those down.
Increased gray matter
in the hippocampus,
which means that they were more
resilient, that they had better
memory, that they were more
focused, that they had reduced
stress.
So these things are, at this
point, scientifically proven.
I come from a Buddhist
background that's
been saying, yeah, we've
been telling you guys
this for 2,600 years.
It's great that you did a
study a couple years ago.
One of my favorite words
within the Buddhist tradition
is gom-- g-o-m.
Very simple word.
Often it's translated
as meditation.
The more exact translation
would be familiarization
or becoming familiar with.
Meditation is a way to become
more familiar with who you are.
That's what I want to
talk to you about today.
Yes, meditation can help
you get better at work,
but frankly, that just
means you're doing more work
and you're better at it.
What I'd like to
talk to you about
is how meditation
is actually going
to change the way that we
work overall, the way that we
view our work, the
way that we consider
what is meaningful work.
Now that meditation
and mindfulness
have become such buzz words
and such activity-- that's
even here in your office.
I was at Indiegogo
a couple months ago.
They have a zen room there.
Apparently, that's where people
go for private phone calls.
When they asked me, where can
we go to meditate in our office?
I said, you have a zen room.
I'm sitting right next to it.
What do you do there?
Now that it has become so
prevalent that we literally
have rooms dedicated to it in
big corporate institutions,
I think it's going to be very
tempting for us to say, oh,
it's just about me becoming
less stressed, which is fine.
I'm a firm believer
that whatever
motivates you to begin a
meditation practice, it's good.
Less stress, I want to work
with my strong emotions,
I'm going through difficult
time, I think this could help.
But the more we
meditate, the more
we realize it's a
practice of becoming
familiar with who we are, both
the amazing and scary parts
of our mind.
So how does this actually
affect the way we work?
This is a big question.
Little bit about me.
I was raised within the
Shambhala Buddhist tradition.
I started meditating
when I was six.
I started doing meditation
retreats when I was 11, then 17
ran off to the monastery in
Nova Scotia-- shaved my head,
took the robes, the
whole nine yards.
Came back, went to
college next year,
and my primary meditation
mudra in those initial weeks
of college was the
keg stand mudra.
Maybe you've heard of
it where you literally
have your hands on the keg and
you're drinking upside down.
So I had this like
moment of really
having to find my particular
balance between what
at the time was work-- school
work-- and also going out
and all of these things.
And meditation was the
through line for me in terms
of finding that balance,
finding what we often
casually refer to as the middle
way within the Buddhist world.
Between going to the extreme
of going out all the time
and really getting stressed
out about work and all
these things, I was able
to find a sense of balance
through the meditation practice.
And it was years
later that I picked up
a book by Pema Chodron.
She's a very well-known
Buddhist teacher.
She's a nun within my
particular tradition.
And in the opening chapters
of "When Things Fall Apart,"
one of her earlier
works, she talks
about coming home and
finding that her husband was
leaving her and that she
had to get a divorce.
I was going through a
heartbreak at the time.
I really was at this
interesting crossroads.
I had been meditating
for some time,
so put a lot of my stock--
my happiness stock--
in a relationship
and it fell through.
So I felt that heartbreak.
I could empathize with that, and
her teachings were so helpful.
In re-reading this
for what might
have been the millionth
time, I thought,
I haven't gone through
a divorce, though.
So who's writing about
that first big breakup?
Who's not writing about
the midlife crisis
but that quarter
life crisis of I
don't know what I want
to do with my life?
Who is writing about going out
with friends on Friday night?
And the more I explored,
the less I could find.
And I ended up writing my
first book, which is called
"The Buddha Walks Into a Bar."
And I think what I
discovered in that process
was that I wasn't alone.
There were a lot of
people of all ages
that wanted to talk about how
could we apply the meditation
practice to all the
areas of our life?
An interesting
thing happens when
you write a book called "The
Buddha Walks Into a Bar."
I went to 36 cities
for that tour.
I would never do that again.
It's exhausting.
If you ever write a book, don't
go to 36 cities in two months.
It's really too much.
But it was also wonderful.
I met a lot of new friends.
I saw a lot of old friends.
And they would come
to these events,
and when you write a book called
"The Buddha Walks Into a Bar,"
right afterwards, you're ready
to collapse and go to sleep.
And they say, you know what
we should do right now?
We should go to a bar.
Funny thing happens when you
go to a bar with friends.
For some of the
younger friends, I
found that we quickly started
talking about that balance.
I'm trying to explore
what I want to do,
what's personally
meaningful for me in work.
And for older friends who are
a little bit more established
in their careers, it's how
do I cultivate the qualities
that one actually cultivate in
meditation in the workplace?
So as soon as we got to the
bar, it all became about work.
And that's how "The Buddha Walks
Into the Office" came about.
Specifically, I was
traveling, and I was not
too far from here.
I was giving a talk at Yale.
And I was met by
a student who was
part of the meditation group.
She's showing me around
campus, and we popped off
for some coffee at Starbucks.
And it came out this she
was about to graduate.
I'm always very
careful with people
who are about to graduate.
Instead of being like, what are
you going to do with your life,
I think I said
something like have
you thought about where you
want to live in a couple months?
Are you going to go home or
are you going to move somewhere
and are there friends you're
going to move in with?
She said, it's so funny that you
ask me these sorts of questions
here at a Starbucks
because I want
to be the CMO--
the chief marketing
officer-- of Starbucks.
Oh, that's very specific.
I asked her a bunch of
questions about that.
I was very curious.
It was really interesting
to see how she got to that.
And then we'll call her Jessica.
Jessica escorted me
back to the talk.
Gave the talk.
Afterwards, signing books
and talking to people,
another woman approached me.
Also, right about to
graduate in a couple months.
Same question.
Have you thought about where
you might want to live?
Well, I have a couple
ideas where I want to live.
I have no idea what I want
to do, and it terrifies me.
And I think that's OK, right?
I said, well, tell me more.
She said, well, all I know
is I want to help people.
And I said that's great.
That's a really
good starting point.
So I left that university campus
and I thought, how interesting
these people were in
the same graduating
class at the same school--
such different views of what
they were going to do.
And I started
thinking about this.
OK, if we're going to talk about
personally-meaningful work--
and these are two people
who are meditating.
They're going to
sit there, they're
going become more
familiar with who they are
and more familiar with
what I would say is
their intention for their work.
And we'll come back
to that in a bit.
But we have Jessica who
is going to go out there
and maybe she'll find a good
job in marketing after college
and she'll keep rising
in the ranks there.
And then she'll move over maybe
somewhere within the coffee
industry-- maybe even
straight to Starbucks
but eventually she'll get there.
And she keeps rising in
the ranks of marketing
at Starbucks.
And all along she's saying,
this is what the goal is.
My sense of happiness comes
from this role-- chief marketing
officer of Starbucks.
Now, two things can happen here.
One she gets the job.
Or two, she doesn't get the job.
So option one-- she
gets the CMO job
after decades of
striving for it.
And what happens when we
get our wish fulfilled
in these sorts of ways?
She might look over her
shoulder and say, oh, I
didn't spend a lot of
time with my family.
I was working so hard.
I wish I'd done more of that.
Or maybe I didn't start a
family of my own along the way.
Or maybe it's not paying me
what I thought I would get paid.
I'm worth more than this.
Or maybe I'm working too much.
This is too many hours,
too much responsibility.
I didn't think
it'd be like this.
Or maybe she gets the
CMO job and she realizes
she doesn't want to be CMO.
She wants to be CEO.
There are lots of
ways that she could
get that particular job title
and still not feel fulfilled.
And then option two,
she doesn't get it.
She spends decades striving
for this particular role,
and it doesn't happen.
And I thought this is not
a great roadmap for success
if we're going to define
success as actually
finding a sense of happiness
or contentment in our work.
We can contrast
this with Christine.
Christine, no clue
what she's doing.
Totally terrified.
But she knows she
wants to help people.
There's 1,000 options for her.
She could go become a teacher.
She could become
a social worker.
She could run a nonprofit.
She could work here.
She could work in
a giant company
but be the person that's always
sticking up for the little guy.
There is any number
of things she
could do if she wants to
be of benefit to others.
If that is what's going to
bring her a sense of contentment
or happiness in her work,
there's so many options
available to her.
That roadmap seems
very joyous to me.
So as I start contemplating
these things--
and as I start contemplating
this whole "Buddha Walks Into
the Office" thing--
I thought, maybe
the question of what we
want to do when we grow,
maybe that's outdated.
Did anyone get that question
when you were a kid?
What do you want to
do when you grow up?
What do you want to be?
I think a lot of us did.
What you want to do
when you grow up?
Maybe that's outdated.
Maybe the better question
today is who do you
want to be when you grow up?
And I should qualify this.
I don't think at a certain
point we just hit a state
and we're like,
now I'm a grownup.
I think we just continue to
grow up and our idea of what
or who we want to be shifts.
As Ben Franklin is
famous for saying,
"when you're finished
changing, you're finished."
So we continue to evolve.
We continue to change.
Our whole understanding
of who we are
can continue to adapt
as we go through life.
But the point of it is can we
bring a sense of intentionality
to our work?
Can we bring a sense
of a singular purpose,
if even for today?
I'm a firm believer that we
always have an intention.
And the question is
are we familiar with it
or not-- to come back
to that term "goal?"
So if you are going out with
friends on a Friday night,
what's your intention
for meeting up with them?
Is it because you haven't
seen them for awhile?
You want to connect?
You want to share good news?
You want to hear their bad news?
What's the intention behind
going out on a Friday night?
Or is it you had
a really hard week
and you want to just get
drunk and forget about it?
Because a shot of tequila
is not good or bad,
but thinking makes it so.
So if we have that shot, it
might muddy our brain a little.
But if we're doing it
to connect with friends,
et cetera, that takes
us down one road
if we're clear about
our intention-- have
a few drinks with friends,
reconnect with them--
as opposed to I don't
know what I'm doing.
I'm just going to go
out and get drunk.
That takes us down a very
different road where we wake up
hungover, not clear what we
did, who we made out with,
what we did, what we said wrong,
open our phone, who did I text?
It's a different road if we're
clear about our intention
and clear about why
we do what we do.
And that's a silly
example, right-- shot
of tequila on a Friday night?
But if we're going
to take a job here
at Google, why are we here?
Why are we doing this work?
It's long hours.
We're here in the
New York office,
and I have a particular
belief that New Yorkers like
to work longer than just
about anywhere else.
So we work long hours-- why?
What's our motivation?
The why shouldn't be because
I have this job title.
The why is because
fill in the blank.
We shouldn't have to build their
career out around what we are
and what our particular role is.
That might change.
In fact, it probably
will change.
If we can build it out
around who we want to be,
the qualities we want
to cultivate day in
and day out, then we can live
a life that's actually happier
and probably is a benefit
to lots of people.
One of the things
I often encourage
people who are contemplating
this sort of work-life balance
is when you wake
up in the morning,
before you even get out of
bed, just lay there and think,
what do I have to do?
Before you go into the stress
of getting nitty gritty
about your schedule,
say, oh, I'm
meeting with these
sorts of people,
seeing this sort
of friend after.
And then you say, what's
my intention for today?
What quality do I want
to cultivate today?
Is it patience because the
people that you're meeting with
are very grating?
Is it presence
because you actually
just want to show up
and appreciate them
for who they are?
Is it gentleness
because you feel
like you've been beating
yourself up and manifesting
in how you interact with others?
What is the quality you want to
cultivate throughout the day?
You could even have
it as the background
of your phone or your
computer, put it on a post-it,
put it up in the office.
And remind yourself, oh,
right-- today, I'm actually
just trying to be gentle.
That would be really significant
if I could just be gentle today
to myself and others.
Today I'm trying to be patient.
Just reminding ourselves
slowly throughout the day.
And then at the end of the day
as we're brushing our teeth--
I often say brushing our
teeth because we often
remember to do that and if we
can associate it with something
we already remember to
do it becomes easier
to do-- we can actually
reflect on how we did today.
Oh, I meant to be patient today.
Did that happen?
Probably not.
OK.
If it didn't happen,
tomorrow is a new day.
New intention, maybe
the same intention.
If it didn't happen,
we should celebrate.
We should acknowledge that.
We should just have a moment
appreciation for the fact
that we're cultivating the
qualities that we would
normally cultivate on
the meditation cushion
in the rest of our life.
This is really for me the beauty
of the meditation practice.
Because we are becoming
more familiar with who
we are as we meditate,
we become more
familiar with both the
aspects of our life
so we want to cultivate
and the aspects of our life
that we might actually need
to cut out a little bit.
And we can have the
discipline to follow through
in our day-to-day life.
I'd like to actually
do a meditation
and exercise with you
all if you'll indulge me.
At this point, there are
a lot of people here.
So we have note
pads in the center,
but maybe not everyone
can have a note pad.
Maybe we can take pieces
of paper and pass it on.
This is one of those
places that everyone
comes in with their laptop
but no one has pen and paper.
So we have pen
and paper for you.
And as those pass through, I'll
just a little bit about what
we're going to do together.
So everyone just grab at least
one piece of paper and a pen.
We're going to
engage in an exercise
that we commonly do at
the nonprofit I founded
a few years ago-- the Institute
for Compassionate Leadership.
So the Institute for
Compassionate Leadership or ICL
as we call it is a six
month training program
for these sorts of
people-- the sort of people
that say I want to go out
and I want to help the world
and I have no f-ing
clue what that means.
So we put them
through program where
they receive meditation
training and related
exercises like deep
listening, empathy training.
We match that with community
organizing training
so that when they get off
the meditation cushion
they can go into
their communities
and effectively empower and
work with others and just
practical leadership skills that
aren't taught in universities
these days like
how to fundraise,
how to negotiate, how to
give and receive feedback,
how to run a meeting.
And over the six month
part-time program
with the Institute of
Compassionate Leadership people
get very clear on how they're
going to help the world, what
that career decision
really looks like,
and they actually
develop the confidence
that they have everything
both within the tools we
give them but also internally
to go out and do that work.
This is the first
exercise we do with them.
I'm going to lead us through it.
This is the way that we
actually map out our intention.
So we'll begin
with a few minutes
of what is called Shamatha
or calm abiding meditation.
And then I'll move us through
a guided contemplation.
And we'll do it somewhat
quickly because I
want to allow some time
for Q&A. But for people
who may be watching
this as a recording,
you could even take
longer for the Shamatha--
the calm abiding
meditation-- longer
for some of the exercises,
and it could last a full 45
minutes on its own.
So let's begin.
For those of you who
are seated in a chair.
You can just sit
a little bit away
from the back of the chair with
your feet firmly on the ground.
And for those of
you on the ground,
you can sit with your
legs loosely crossed.
For those of you
standing, you can just
do what I'm doing, which is
slightly bend your knees.
But in all these cases,
we make a firm connection
with the earth underneath us,
giving our [INAUDIBLE] bones
digging into the chair or
the floor or our feet digging
into the earth.
And from the strong
base, we actually
elongate upward
through the spine.
So don't lift up
through your shoulders.
Literally feel as
if there is a string
at the top of your head
pulling you straight up.
So the spine can actually be
like stack of quarters, one
on top of the other.
Relaxing the muscles in our
shoulders and in our back.
If you're standing, you can
just let your hands fall
at your sides.
If you are seated, you can
pick them up at the elbows
and drop them palms
down on the thighs.
This is to promote
resting energy
and it also provides extra
support for our back.
For many of us, we're
used to slouching.
So hopefully this will give you
a little bit of extra support.
The chin just rests at
the top of the spine,
tucking the chin
ever so slightly.
And bring a sense of relaxation
to the muscles in your face.
Relaxing the jaw.
So the jaw hangs open.
You can place your tongue
up against the roof
of your mouth, which slows down
the swallowing process, which
can be distracting.
It allows for clear breathing.
This particular practice
is one within which
we wake up to what is going
on in this very moment.
We wake up to the
present moment.
So let's actually
keep our eyes open
since we are
attempting to wake up.
You can rest of your gaze
two to four feet ahead of you
on the ground in a loose
and unfocused manner.
The object or meditation
is the breath,
both the physical
sensation of the out breath
and the in breath.
So you don't need to change or
alter your breathing at all,
just allow it to occur
as it always does.
In fact, the only
difference between now
and the rest of our
day is that we're
paying full attention to it.
So just feel the breath as
it cycles through your body.
And when you notice that
your mind drifts off
into thinking about the past--
perhaps a conversation you had
earlier in the day-- or the
future-- plans for tonight,
things you need to accomplish--
just come back to the breath.
Let it anchor you
in the present.
The breath is always fresh.
It is always what is
going on right now.
If it's helpful, you
could even gently
say "thinking" to yourself.
When a big thought comes
up, we just acknowledge it.
We don't say it's a good
thought or bad though.
We just say thinking and
return our focus to the breath.
Now, I would like
to ask that we shift
our focus to a contemplation.
We'll just hold a
simple question in mind
and come back to it
in the same manner
that we are coming
back to the breath.
What quality would I like
to cultivate in my life?
Just notice whatever
responses may come up
to the simple question.
Let them wash over
you like a wave.
And when you notice you've got
distracted from the question,
come back to it.
What quality would I like
to cultivate in my life?
OK, you can raise your gaze.
And what I'd like to
ask at this point is
in the corner of
your paper, just
jot down a few of
those responses
that came up-- those qualities.
No one will see this but
you, unless you upload it
to Google, in which case I feel
like everyone could see it.
Just a few will do.
And now I'm going
to ask you to draw
in the entirety of your page a
series of concentric circles--
four or five will do.
So one in the center and
then another one around it
and another one around that
and then one more around that.
So just a series.
It looks like almost
a bullseye-- bullseye
with a dartboard.
Can I borrow your
piece of paper?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
LODRO RINZLER: So for those of
you who are visual learners,
this is a perfect example--
she gets an A-- of what
I'm talking about.
Within the Buddhist
tradition, there
is something called a mandala.
And people may have heard of it.
If you're "House of
Cards" fans, people
saw the sand mandala--
very elaborate.
Went on for weeks or months
and then they tossed it.
Often these are depicted
in lasting form in what are
known as Thangkas-- paintings.
And in the center, there is
a central deity or lineage
figure, and then
in the next circle
out, there are various
manifestations of that deity
or lineage figure--
different parts
of their life, different
aspects of who they are.
And it continues on and on
until all sentient beings
are represented.
Particularly, I like to use the
example of the wheel of life
because it has
passion, aggression,
ignorance at the
center and then there's
different ways that
our ego plays it out
and the different
realms we're said to be
born in and so on and so forth.
So it gets very vast
at a certain point.
But there's always
something at the center.
Our lives are a mandala,
and there's always
something at the center.
And we are either
consciously aware of it
or we are unconsciously
living it.
It could be our job title.
A lot of times, it
is our job title.
If we're just going through
life not paying much attention
to our intentions, it might
be our specific role-- author,
nonprofit directory, whatever.
And then you build your
life out around that
because that's the primary
way that you spend your hours.
CMO of Starbucks, and then you
build your life out around it.
What I'd like to ask is that you
look at that list of qualities
that you just jotted down and
see if one of them stands out.
And when it does, write that
at the center of the Mandala.
Now I'd like to invite
you to contemplate
all the other
amazing things that
are in your life-- your family,
your friends, your work.
Your work can certainly
be part of this.
Your extracurricular
activities--
do you like to read, do you go
to museums, do you sing opera,
do you go to the ballet,
do you run, do you do yoga,
do you meditate?
And however significant these
things are to you in your life,
the closer they are to the
center of that mandala.
So if you're very
close with your mom,
she's in that next circle out.
If you're not very close with
your mom, she's farther out.
As you jot down and start
free associating with some
of these things,
there's someone that
is in your life--
a good friend--
but you haven't
seen them forever.
Maybe they're further
out right now.
We're not evaluating where
we think they should be.
We're just looking at the
reality of our situation.
Where are the beings and
the activities in our life?
Just jotting down a whole
bunch-- maybe even 10 to 20
would do.
Just real free association.
If you're having trouble,
you can even just
think about the
people and things
that you've done the last week.
That's often a good indicator.
So the more significant
they are to you,
the closer they
are to the center.
The less significant
they are, further out.
We're not trying to judge.
If your mother is in your third
circle, I'm not going to know.
Just you.
It's fine.
Do you have pets?
You could put pets in there.
Volunteer activities
you might be engaged in.
You can put that in there.
Do you go biking?
Do you run?
Do you have an eccentric hobby?
And then when
you're ready, I want
to invite you to
draw a thin line
from the center of that
mandala out to those things
that you just wrote down.
Just a very thin line.
So if you have kindness at
the center of your mandala,
you just draw a small
line out to your mother,
to running, to
your close friend.
So as we map out this
mandala of our life
with a quality that we want to
cultivate at the center of it,
what shifts?
What changes?
So if you were to infuse-- I'll
continue with the example I
gave-- kindness into these
various areas of your life,
what would that look like?
So in the example of drawing
that line from kindness
to my mother, it means
that when my mother calls,
I should pick up.
That would be good of me.
I shouldn't just put it off
for when I feel it's best.
It's kind to actually pick up.
I'm available.
So whatever comes to mind.
Just starting to map out.
You could just jot it down.
I realize that your mandala is
about to become very crowded
with all these long phrases.
But just little notes.
Pick up phone.
What does kindness mean injected
into your exercise schedule?
What does kindness mean in
relationship to those friends
that you have mapped out?
What does kindness
mean in relationship
to how you take care of
your body or how you eat?
Whatever's on the piece
of paper right now,
just making a
simple note of ways
that you would inject your
quality at the center-- not
kindness if it's not kindness.
Gentleness, patience,
generosity--
whatever you have
written down, how
do you inject that into
that relationship more
than you already have?
How can you go further
with cultivating
that quality in relationship to
all these things in your life?
When you're ready,
I'd like to invite
you to return to the
basic shamatha practice
that we were doing before.
You don't have to rush
if you're still writing.
But when you are done writing,
reconnecting to that meditation
posture that we reviewed
before and then reconnecting
to the breath.
You can raise your
gaze once more
and come back to the group.
In the Tibetan tradition,
we say many short sessions
within the day.
That's the way to enlightenment.
So lots of little
periods of meditation.
The more we start to
build our life out
around the qualities we want
to cultivate in our life,
the more contentment
we will find.
The more we're actually
just tuning into what
we actually see as the
source of happiness.
And we're less directed by
just the external factors
that exist in our world.
We're not putting those in the
center of the mandala-- my job
title.
We're actually building our life
out around something that feels
personally meaningful to us.
And this is how meditation
will actually help
us discover who we want to be.
We'll become
familiar with who we
want to be as opposed
to just what we
want to do-- the activity
that busies our life.
That way we could collect
garbage for a living or we
could run a hedge
fund, but we are being
who we want to be at work.
We always have that opportunity
to cultivate the qualities
that we want to see in ourselves
and in the world and our life.
So thank you so much for
joining with me for the Buddha
Walks Into the Office
and experimenting
with this contemplation
that we do
at the Institute for
Compassionate Leadership.
I'd love to hear what
questions or reflections
you may have on that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LODRO RINZLER: So
what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Olivia.
LODRO RINZLER: Olivia.
So a beautiful question.
It's like, OK, this
is fine and good,
but my life is
really f-ing busy.
So my theory is
holding weight, right?
We are actually very busy.
We do work long hours here.
I remember years ago my
teacher Sakyong Mipham Rinpoche
he was giving a very
traditional Buddhist talk
and then he started talking
about the power of prayer.
And I was like, what
is going on here?
This just became very
Christian for me.
And I started getting
really inquisitive.
And what I realized
he was saying
is sometimes the most
powerful thing we can do
is to voice an aspiration--
to actually just give voice
to I want to be kind,
I want to be patient,
I want to do that today.
And just saying it-- or in
our case, what we just did
is actually writing it out.
Not just writing it out,
but writing out all the ways
we could do it reminds us
that we can do it differently
than we normally do.
This is us literally
mapping out different things
we could do within one given
day to cultivate that quality we
want to cultivate.
And as I mentioned,
there are many ways
we could reminder
ourselves beyond this.
If you wanted, you could pin
this to your desk or something
like that.
But you could also write out the
quality you want to cultivate.
You could have it pop up as
a reminder on your calendar.
You could have a timer on your
phone go off to remind you.
One of the things
I do when I notice
I'm working on one project for
a really long period of time
is I set a timer on
the phone to go off.
And I'll work away if I'm
writing a book or something
and the timer goes off
and I close the laptop
and I raise my gaze and I
just reconnect to the breath.
I cut through the habitual speed
of the day-to-day momentum,
reconnect, then after
30 seconds or a minute,
I notice I start to get busy.
I should get back to work.
I open the laptop.
I reset the phone an hour
later, I do it again.
And that way, I actually
slowed down in little ways
throughout the day.
And that helps me remember
why I'm doing what I'm doing.
Is that helpful?
It's worth experimenting with.
We can get very
tricky with ourselves.
Because our mind is very tricky.
It wants to speed up and
get distracted and do
all sorts of things.
We can get tricky with
how we focus it, too.
Other questions or comments?
AUDIENCE: So I get this idea
of cultivating the quality
in your life over a
longer period of time,
but can you talk
more about how you
can cultivate those qualities--
like daily qualities--
and do you recommend
trying new things?
I want to practice
being patient today
even if it deviates
from the longer term
quality I'm cultivating.
LODRO RINZLER: This exercise
we do, as I mentioned,
I do at the beginning
of the six month program
for the Institute for
Compassionate Leadership.
I also often do it around
New Year's because people
want to set a resolution.
It's always like lose
weight-- not gain weight.
I don't think many
people have that one.
Lose weight.
But that's actually part
of a larger motivation
for what we want to do in terms
of taking care of ourselves
and et cetera, et cetera.
So sometimes we put the
cart before the horse.
We could do this exercise
even on a daily basis
or we could just wake
up in the morning
and say, all right,
what's coming up for me?
How can I bring out
the things I need
to bring out today in myself?
The Buddhist point of view
is that we actually have
everything we need within us.
So the Buddha was a human
being like you and me.
And he came from a
life of a lot of luxury
and then once he
realized that there
was suffering in the world,
he was very cloistered,
very sheltered.
He didn't realize that.
So once he realized
it, he actually
went to the opposite
extreme-- a life
of real asceticism--
literally torturing himself
in the name of spirituality.
And as I mentioned
earlier, he gradually
found a middle way
between those two.
And when he did that, he
discovered that he was awake--
not that he could be awake,
it's that he was awake.
And he was confused but
then he can actually
discover and have confidence
in his natural wakefulness.
So it said that we all
possess the same thing
that he did-- what we
would call Tathagatagarbha,
which is Buddha nature.
We all possess Buddha nature.
It's not like he was better
than us or something like that.
It's just he
discovered it and then
he laid out this path
and this practice.
The practice he
did 2,600 years ago
is the same practice we
started off with today.
So we can go through
this practice of becoming
familiar with who we are.
The more we look,
the more we discover
that there's some sense of
peace-- some semblance of peace
right at the center
of who we are--
beyond all of the confusion and
distraction and the busyness
and all of the things that get
in our head throughout the day.
Within the Shambhala
tradition we sometimes
call this that we're
basically good.
We're basically wise.
We're basically kind.
We're basically strong.
We're basically capable.
We're basically worthy.
We're basically able
to accommodate whatever
vicissitudes life throws at us.
So sometimes it's a little
overwhelming to say,
oh, I wake up, I
want to be patient,
and then I go into my
day and act like a jerk.
But we have this
wellspring within us
that we can always
touch in with.
So the more we
meditate, the easier
it becomes to just come back to
the sense of peaceful abiding--
the calm abiding,
which is literally
the name of the meditation
practice we were doing.
So the more we discover
that, the more we
can have confidence
in that, the more
we can actually bring it
out in our day-to-day life.
And that's how we make
these intentions really
strong and powerful.
So that's my advice.
It's a long winded way saying we
should probably meditate more.
No surprise there
coming from me.
Thank you for that
question, though.
Others?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Meditation
helps for work for sure,
but on the other hand,
when you do meditate a lot,
it also conflicts with
craving for success,
going higher,
competing with others.
And those are the things that
big companies need these days
for bigger achievements.
So you need to be
hungry for success,
hungry for going higher.
So that conflicts with
meditation, right?
LODRO RINZLER: So the question
is meditation meditation,
all nice and good in the
workplace, but at some point
we're not sitting here talking
about ambition-- achieving
more, doing more, creating more
so that the business thrives,
et cetera.
So isn't there a conflict here?
And it's a really good question.
I have a few answers.
The first is whatever
our version of more
is, there's always going
to be more above that.
So in the example of our friend,
Jessica, she becomes CMO.
She's become very ambitious.
She gets that great title.
There's going to be
more that she wants.
This is just the
nature of what we
would call within Buddhism the
cycle of suffering-- samsara.
There's always going to be more.
So what I'm asking us to
do is to consider success,
even at a corporate
level, as something
other than getting bigger.
I mean, we have this
society that says,
well, you should
always be doing more.
It's not good enough
that you have this job.
You should have another
job that's better.
It's not good enough that
you have the iPhone five,
you should have an
iPhone 6 at this point.
There's always going to be
something more that we can get,
and then when we get it,
we'll want something else.
So that's suffering.
That's the very nature of
suffering we're talking about.
So is this expected
in us for business?
Yes and no.
I have a theory I'd
like to present today
that I've just been recently
contemplating that--
and it's based on something
that my teacher Sakyong Mipham
Rinpoche said.
He said sometimes when
we talk about society,
we can get easily
overwhelmed because we
are talking about
I'm here in New York,
there is suffering because
of the earthquake in Nepal
and there's suffering
in Baltimore
and there's all these
things, and I'm not there.
What can I do?
And we become disheartened.
And he said society
could actually just
be two people sitting
down having tea.
That's a society right there.
So if you and I had tea and
we had an hour together,
we sipped our tea, we were
actually present with it,
and we talked about things
that really mattered
to us, that would be
one type of society
that you and I
created for an hour.
Or we could sit down and get
distracted on our phones,
not really pay attention to the
tea, and occasionally look up
and talk poorly about others
and slander them and say what
a jerk they are.
And that's a whole
other type of society
that you and I
create for one hour.
We were always creating society.
This is my theory.
So if society can just be two
people sitting down having tea,
we have 50% stakeholder
in that society.
I work with a lot of
meditation students one-on-one.
And there's a woman who is a
nurse practitioner in Minnesota
and her name is Nicole.
And Nicole is 1/10 of
her private practice.
There's 10 people
that work there.
So I said you are
1/10 of this society.
So sometimes when
we go to work--
and I don't mean
to pick on Nicole.
She's a wonderful human being
and an excellent meditator
and all these things.
Sometimes when we
go to work we say,
this is the way things are.
How do I put up with it?
How do I put up with
the ambition thing?
the speed thing?
That thing that people are
always expecting more of me,
people want me to work longer
hours, whatever it might be.
And instead of saying, how do
I put up with this society?
I'd like to ask, how do
you create that society?
So in Nicole's case,
she's 1/10 of it.
So she sits down with
one person and says,
you know, it seems
like we all continue
to email each other after
10 o'clock at night.
Do you like that?
I don't like that.
And that person says, no,
I don't like that either.
All of a sudden,
20% of that society
wants to put down their
email after a certain hour.
And then maybe they
talk to a third person
and 30% of that society
doesn't want to do it.
And this is how we actually
create change within cultures--
through conversation,
through genuinely
showing up with someone and
sharing our heart in that way.
This is counter to what a
lot of our corporate society
encourages.
But I think in a
company like this,
it would be understood
and respected
that we could show up and
voice how we would like
to see a society like this run.
Because Google is a society.
You guys know this.
And you wield incredible
power in society overall.
So even just starting with a
conversation with a coworker
could have tremendous
results worldwide.
We live in an
interconnected society,
and you guys know
this very well.
I'm not telling
you guys anything
that you don't already know.
In fact, if I had to define
the job description of Buddhist
meditation teachers,
telling people things
they already know.
Oh, I can just meditate and be
present, that's interesting.
But I digress.
You guys have an amazing ability
to connect with many people,
even within today,
even within this room.
We can start here and say
maybe my version of ambition
is to create a
culture of kindness.
Maybe my version of
ambition is to have us all
be very gentle with each
other-- to encourage patience.
And then even within
the one meeting
we run every week, that
starts to ripple out
and other people say
I want to do that too.
And then that influences
Google as a company
and it influences
people in their homes.
And the way I pulled
this from is a story
at the time of the Buddha.
And I guess I'll end on this
one in looking at our time.
There's a story at
the time of the Buddha
that there is a king
known as Dawa Sangpo.
And he heard tell of the Buddha.
I don't know how people heard
of each other in those days.
Maybe he saw his
video on YouTube.
Who's to say.
But he decides that
he needs to study
with this great
meditation master.
So he travels a great
distance, and when he arrives,
he's a little
disheartened because he
realizes that all the
Buddha's followers are
monastics at that time.
And he can't do it.
So he goes to the
Buddha and he says,
I have this entire kingdom
of people relying on me.
What can I do?
I can't become a monk, but
I want to receive teachings.
And the Buddha asked all
of this monastic followers
to leave the room
and imparted what's
known now as Kalachakra
Chandra on King Dawa Sangpo.
These are teachings of
mindfulness and compassion.
So the same teachings we
offer at the Institute
for Compassionate Leadership.
And it is said that King Dawa
Sangpo went back to his kingdom
and he started talking to people
and he started meditating.
And he would be in a meeting
with his ministers of education
and he would say,
how can we get people
to be more present in
our education system?
And they'd all say, oh,
this is interesting.
They'd have that
sort of conversation.
And then ultimately, the
more they talked about it,
the larger the
ramifications were.
Because in the schools
of that kingdom,
people were actually starting
to talk about mindfulness
and compassion.
And then he would
meet with his generals
and he would say, OK, how can
we take care of our troops?
How can we support them best?
And it was just such a
different question then
what they might
have already had.
There would be
conversations around that
and that would affect
the whole army.
And then he would have questions
around the major doctors
an area.
He would gather them
together and talk to them
and all of a sudden
the medical system
would be transformed
with the idea
of deep care for the patients.
And yes, he was a King.
But it's said that just
through conversation,
he was able to influence
this giant kingdom.
It's not like he came in and
said, we're now a Buddhist .
Kingdom.
No.
It wasn't this top-down thing.
It was organic.
It was conversations
amongst people.
And this is a kingdom, and it's
legendary and may or may not
have existed.
But it was known as Shambhala.
So that's the template from
which this particular Buddhist
tradition I practice
in flourishes.
We come from the
tradition of maybe
if we can show up one-on-one
and just be with people,
be authentic with them
and share our heart,
maybe real change can
be created in our world.
So thank you very much
for your question,
and thank you all so much
for having me here at Google.